our goal here was to create what we
believe is the first RPG where the mage
is a total badass okay and one of the
ways that we started approaching this is
we looked at what a lot of games have
implemented and the sort of constraints
they place on mages to make them equal
to other classes that they put in the
game and we eliminated them so we took
away things like Nana bars and cool
downs and what's really interesting
about that is when we tell people that
they usually come back and say well
doesn't that in the mean the game is
going to be trivial because you can just
cast as much magic as you want to write
you're not limited the game is actually
very very challenging and I think Josh
will give you an idea of how challenging
it can be yeah so as the producer on the
game obviously I play it quite a bit and
I practice the four packs to get ready
and I came in feeling kind of confident
and I said to myself that I didn't want
to die a single time at PAX we're doing
about 60 demos for crowds of 20 folks
and I felt like I'd be embarrassed if I
ever died once and then on Friday over
the course of the day I died 24 times so
that gives you some sense of this is not
an easy game by any stretch it's not
impossible it's a lot of fun but it's
definitely a challenge and you need to
learn the skills to play it properly so
another thing that we did is you know we
took a look at how we've been
conditioned to play mages in
over the years and we have terms like
glass cannon and squishy right which
mean I can deal out a lot of damage but
I can never stand toe-to-toe with an
enemy I need to run away from them i
need to kite things like that and we
wanted to eliminate that so we decided
to focus on a couple of defensive
abilities and we weaponize them so your
block as an example which is on the
right mouse button when you block you
ignore half of all damage however if you
time your block perfectly then you're
not only invulnerable to all damage for
that brief window but if you're hit by
an enemy like like this you will
detonate whatever spell that you haven't
wet so when you can actually turn your
defensive block into an offensive weapon
and it's really visceral feeling then
the other defensive ability is your
magical dodge or a blink and when you do
that you have a short teleport and
wherever you land your again going to
detonate whatever spell you have a quit
so now instead of running away from your
enemies constantly you can dodge into
your enemies and then block them and
just really fight toe-to-toe and it's
it's very very visible we've got some
pretty awesome voice talent in the game
our female hero is voiced by jennifer
hale and Troy Baker does the male hero
and we've also got Gina Torres and
Clancy Brown doing voice work for us so
really incredible cast of characters in
the game this area right here is
something kind of neat we call these
loot machines right now and these are
challenges that are sprinkled all
through the game and they all work
differently this particular one when you
hit it with a spell it starts an event
that starts spawning waves of enemies in
this case for our waves and every time
you kill an enemy if they drop loot
you'll notice the loot doesn't actually
go to the player they
goes up into the machine instead and as
more loot is added in the machine the
loot that's in there will promote to a
better and better quality and you can
get to the point where like in this case
right now there's a legendary in there
however you can't get any of that loop
unless you beat the entire encounter and
if you die at any point you lose all the
loot that's there and you got to come
back and try it again these are optional
areas are designed to be very
challenging but very rewarding at the
cleric and accomplished as you can see
josh is on his last leg here he's got
his last shield pip up he took a lot of
damage because this mini boss right here
in the last wave she's a banshee she
does a scream that will stun you and she
stuns you right in the middle of enemies
he could go pretty poorly right when
she's by herself when you get to the end
she's not so bad
that's correct there's no madam nope
yeah there's no man oh there's no you
know there's we have a couple of systems
like your blink is something you can't
spam it you can just use it over and
over again but they're in there are no
cool downs or anything that interrupts a
player for more than two or three
seconds so now that josh has completed
that room he's got a ton of loot right
from that glute machine so he's going to
go ahead and craft a little bit explain
how that works so I'm about to make my
way into a boss battle here and for that
I'm going to need some better spells all
the loot in the game is focused on being
able to craft yourself new magical
spells and so for a quick demonstration
I'm gonna grab some new fire spells to
fight the boss with so I choose my fire
sigil and my strategy is going to be to
apply a debuff to him using a mastery
focus spell so I'm building a targeted
spell and I'm going to augment it with
mastery and when I crap that and equip
it that goes into my arsenal then I'm
going to craft a barrier spell and I'm
going to use that for damage I've got a
lot of choices here I like this one and
I'm going to add destruction to this so
the basic idea is light them on fire and
get them burning with this mastery
debuff I then follow up with my barrier
spell which I can cast by either
blinking or blocking and that's going to
do bonus damage against them fun in here
i'll do an AoE as well just to round out
the Arsenal and more destruction because
destruction helps so now I've equipped
all my new spells I've got my old spell
sitting in my inventory and they're not
useful to me anymore so I'm going to go
into our synthesis screen where you can
synthesize any of the lewd or spells in
the game in two different stuff so I've
got three fire spells here if I
synthesize it
actually upgrades my entire fire sigil
so now I've got a better global chance
of getting Fritz when I cast any fire
spell and of course throughout the game
you can continue to upgrade your fire
sigil so if you say I'm a fire mage you
can do that and you can really focus all
your efforts on building up your fire
and coming up with different strategies
for how to pass fire effectively so one
of the things we did here too and our
bosses on you know if you've ever played
a mage in a game and you decided to
maybe take a different route you said
I'm gonna make a mind-control mage right
it's all about manipulating my enemies
then you get to the boss and find out
all your spell's are useless because
none of them will work on the boss right
well we don't do that we let everything
work on the boss seat including crowd
control and everything else but what we
do is win a cost becomes crowd control
they don't like it so we have an enraged
mechanic that the more you crowd control
them the more enrage they get and if
they could they go full-on and rage they
go crazy they're immune to crowd control
for the period of our age they attack
harder they attack bastard they become
very very violent and you can't crawl
control them during that time
that will eventually wear off but you
can do it again so here he's in rage
right now because it was frozen too much
and if he hits now what's interesting is
even though he's enrage you can still
play him tota to hope but it's much
harder right because if you miss here's
a third you can't afford the mistakes
but yeah that's a big attack there so
the so for example if you had a mind
control spell and the boss summoned a
bunch of ads one of the strategies could
be to mind control the boss he'll kill
all the ads and then you go back to
fight the boss but now you got to fight
him enraged right
so we really wanted to make it where the
players could decide on the place now
they want right if you want to stand
back and be a nuker then you can do that
and we you know you can crowd control
the boss and back and hit him as hard as
you can with all those spells if you
want to fight him toe-to-toe and never
leave you know that's what I like to do
I like to stand my ground and make the
enemies move around you can do that too
just grab the spills what you want to do
it and learn how to use those tools so
if you notice that Josh Hill hit him
with this charged up targeted fire spell
in it so a standard the standard blink
explosion was 98 damage but when he
charges up the target and fire spell in
blanks it's doing 168 m so by lighting
them on fire and then blinking into him
he's getting a bonus of them
so the game is going to be available on
August 26 on Steam we're in early access
right now and Josh why don't you tell us
about the milestones we have coming up
yeah so the games available to purchase
via early access on Steam right now for
twenty dollars on in just a couple of
weeks on April twenty-eighth we're doing
our first big early access update that
has changes to a lot of the mechanics
and fundamental rebalancing of magic
that's all based on community feedback
about six weeks after that we go into
alpha and then from there you get access
to more content but the price goes up
incrementally until when it releases in
August it's going to be forty dollars so
you decide whether you want to buy in
now and help us build the game or wait
until it's a little more finished and
polished